i've done some really terrible tv shows
you know i did one show where i played
an undercover cop on a harley during the
day
and a rock star at night it's called
sunset beat
i've gotten the job but i didn't know
how to play the guitar and there'd be
like a full like concert of like you
know
8 000 people out there and be up there
pretending to play guitar i don't even
know how to move my hands you know
during that those 14 years or something
did you ever say geez i got to give this
up i got to
find something else the truth of the
matter is
the first two years you know i was broke
i was sleeping on the floor or closet
and i had a
didn't have a car i rode a bicycle all
around hollywood for auditions and
you know and i did construction work and
a lot of you know
other jobs to get by but once i started
working
um i was making you know enough money
that i didn't have to take another job
so
i always felt like you know i'm a
journeyman actor i'm just going to keep
plugging away and
you know hopefully i'll get some good
rolls as i go i didn't think i was going
to get
as late you know it was a 35 when it hit
so just
amazing i mean because you were doing
like facts of life uh
golden girls you ron rosen i remember
when you
said you you know you were you were
doing that gig you don't feel
like you know what i should give it up
because obviously what was i going to
give up
go back and sell ladies shoes that's by
the way
let me just say that it's a shocking
thing
when being in the selling women's shoes
is shocking like first of all all women
lie about the size of their foot
i don't know why that is so true they
don't want you to like you've seen me
this is a seven and you go this is a ten
you know
you're trying to jam this ten into a
seven
right but there was a whole generation
of these women this is like 1979 1980
and i was working this department store
and there's a whole generation of women
who
so probably were born like in 1910 or
something
that got their you know their fourth
toe cut off right so they could fit into
the pumps
really the toes would fit what are your
other jobs was they had this
this wooden shoe horn and it had it was
like a mr potato head had all these
holes in it with a plastic corn
i remember those and they would come in
and i'd have to i'd have to spread
blue powder on their corn
what a horrible job put the shoe on it
and then go and look and then put the
corn and stretch a cornhole
what you're saying george is that when
you're on the set
of the attack of the killer tomatoes
you're going this is fantastic
i am not putting powder on corns when
i'm
when i'm sandpapering my bat nipples off
still going
i'm good man